the coronavirus has devastated public
transportation dozens of Transit workers
have died and systems across the United
States are also threatened by big
declines in ridership and the revenue
New York City voluntarily shut down its
subway system overnight for the first
time in 115 years all 472 stations will
be closed and cleaned along with trains
from 1 o'clock in the morning to five
o'clock in the morning for the
foreseeable future molo lanky is in a
Manhattan subway station that was
disinfected a few hours ago Mulla
another sign of the times in this
coronavirus world what's it like there
now well Gail good morning you know I'm
sure what you'd noticed out here one
just how empty it is I mean we see two
people here but certainly not what it
typically is during a normal rush-hour
but also how clean it is what they've
been doing is wiping down and
disinfecting really anything anyone
might touch from the entrances to where
you swipe to the turn wheels here
guardrails escalators anything anyone
might put their hands on has been wiped
down and disinfected and the MTA has
added 1100 bus services to their routes
for folks who have been affected by
these overnight closures and free car
rides for essential workers who can't
easily access those bus services but
before New Yorkers and really all
Americans feel safe and comfortable
about commuting again public transit
must be clean
extraordinary times call for
extraordinary measures to protect the
safety and public health of our
customers and our employees just before
closing down New York subways MTA
chairman and CEO Pat Foy called this the
most extensive cleaning operation in
their history
it'll cost hundreds of millions of
dollars in displace ten to eleven
thousand overnight subway riders but boy
says it's necessary it's inconvenient
that is why for essential workers and
first responders we put this
extraordinary level of bus service on
we're out there up close and personal
with a lot of these people you know we
don't know who is sick we don't know who
is not a tough reality for drivers like
Paul Gilmore who work on the front lines
each day his colleague is one of more
than a hundred MTA workers who have died
from the virus this is very sad you see
this man day in and day out there's a
nice gentleman a very good guy at our
garage it's and it's a second family
sure the effects of the pandemic on
public transportation are palpable
nationwide in Minneapolis
Metro Transit has seen a nearly 80
percent decrease in ridership since the
end of February in San Francisco buses
were visibly vacant last month and 60 of
the city's 89 municipal transportation
routes are currently suspended the
reduction in service has caused concern
over limited access to essential
services I think the cut was really
dramatic and drastic I don't want the
busses stopping I want everybody to be
able to do what they want to do you know
but almost half of Americans say they
would not return to public places until
they're confident the outbreak is over
and back in New York this is one car on
the J train tonight subway cars have
increasingly become a shelter for the
homeless creating unsanitary conditions
two homeless men were found dead on
subway cars within 12 hours last week
the causes of death are unknown
the MTA hopes overnight closures will
help but images of crowded trains at the
height of the pandemic have many
wondering if cleaning is enough Phillip
la cheese author of the last subway
you're on the subway first thing in the
morning you know it'll be much safer
the end of the day though when you have
millions of people ride in this subway
system people who are walking around who
are touching the turnstile who are
holding on to the to the the pole in
this subway car so they don't fall down
so you still have to be really careful
the MTA says it's looking at several
cleaning methods from using
antimicrobial treatments to disinfecting
services with UV light Tony all right
Mona thank you very much